il y autant de squeeze la vôtre
aujourd'hui on se retrouve sur flop bird
qui n'est plus disponible sur le ps
store ni sur l'apple store et c'est
vraiment vraiment dommage un adieu
shepherd ont aimé est bien fait parce à
égalité c'est tragique
j'ai énormément joué à ce jeu je suis
vraiment extrêmement fort vous éviter de
voir le constater attention à la on va
partir sur un score qui dépasse au moins
au moins les ai pas mal ou pas à aux
matières un oiseau bleu non attends
nombreux là non l'annoncé possible qui a
fait zéro sur ce jeu [ __ ] y'a juste
l'espace pour vraiment mais voilà mais
non mais là c'est pas possible tu agis
je suis vraiment nul [ __ ] quand je
vois les gens qui font des des scores de
sens là où même deux le 50 mais j'ai
aucune idée de comment ils font mes cd
les sortes de machines à jouer la garder
sa petite elle s'agite et là un ils
pourraient pas juste volé coated
allemand pourrait pas faire ça tout seul
un sans même qu'on ait besoin de toucher
l'écran et ouais j'avais ardue que
j'adore faire c'est ça et ils y voient
là et faire un
c'est compris dans le din hm je sens
qu'on tient quelque chose là là là là je
le sens bien voilà c'est un enjeu de
fourbe passé mais tard mais je parle en
même temps là à maintenant aussi une
petite poussière
voilà c'est bon regardez son oeil son
nom y est plus grand que sa bouche a eu
sinon et pour elle a une bouche
[ __ ] ça d'oiseaux plus tu t'approches
de ton record - tu respires et moi tu
joues bien alors là je suis en apnée
j'ai quand même faire un 14c fond plat
il tombe comme ça et tu les regardes
regarder le koweït dont je te sa
mandature de ballon de rugby à la
défaite
on n'a pas trop envie d'ajouter là comme
ça dans leur antre de grands poteaux
[ __ ] je suis mauvais l'aca pas sérieux
quoique on perd et qu'on tombe sur un
tuyau il ne rentre pas dans le tuyau
poreux sauvage
bref d'espoir expliquer aussi elle pour
qui ce passe passe à tak et hop de
l'autre côté comme ça hein pourquoi
pourquoi le mec a fait jouer est un fils
de chien c'est toujours un mais 2 2 tu
te rends compte de ce que c'est tu te
rends pas toutefois trois oiseaux qui a
délivré des yeux je parle une langue un
cp berne
j'aime bien la 1a ça va bien à quand il
n'est pas sur la chute de 20 mètres
après je suis sûr que depuis ce jeu est
sorti le temps que les gens passent aux
toilettes à kara beau quadruple et tu
vas devant les toilettes chez toi et tu
es sûr besoin de ça c'est obligatoire
ça va tu t'entraînes de kung fu hu est à
suivre
je pratique la nullité du mauvais mais
c'est un truc que j'ai remarqué quand tu
es dans le métro c'est que le mec à côté
de potes et regarde obligatoirement et
du coup tu joues encore plus ta vie
puisque a pas envie de faire un score
nul tu as envie un peu de
l'impressionner et du coup quand tu fais
voilà 4 et tu sais qui te regardes tu
fais je descends là attention si on peut
atteindre les 30
ce serait formidable levier straumann
voilà donc la stromae et ben oui j'ai
fait un mort oh oh oh ah mais non mais
non mais le côté du doubs le poil de
tuyaux quoi je suis dans une ville où il
ya placement je n'ai pas pu les prendre
sinon je me rase tout élément oui j'ai
des lèvres je pratique aussi la
chirurgie esthétique
j'aime tes yeux bat pour bien voir les
tuyaux ou non elle n'est pas une m
c'est une feuille de papier a4 et me
permet de vous les toits de pâtissier et
aussi de mourir contre un gros tuyau wef
et du goût et cette lampe
attendez je suis en temps d'aimer un
matelas si on appuie sur l'art et flavie
beurre version 1 2 3 à la la comme je
m'amuse et c'est qu'on accueille que la
marque etap table je pense toujours dès
que je le vois à cette [ __ ] de
chansons et
suit à peu de tap tap
cette fois on part sur un record du
monde agricole
voilà deux ne rigolez pas un
cette fois mais attend maintenant il
faut pas que je parle
si je parle pas ça va aller mais non je
n'avais pas le droit pourrait même être
la musique générique du marché qui n'a
mis que ça irrite très très bien aussi
regarder ouais
maintenant on va papa ouais non peuvent
l'époux que tu fais c'est pas mal aussi
de rester sur la cour d'accueil mais
j'aime bien je vis dans une ville avec
des tuyaux
oui c'est la peur qui fait rager des
millions d'utilisateurs
oh oui c'est les frappes hibberd qui est
un oiseau mais à délivrer des yeux c'est
la peur de qui a un pétale de fleur à la
place de l'est l'ancien rappeur mais
c'est un oiseau mais il a la forme d'une
olive la terreur j'en ai marre j'en veux
plus si j'atteins lui dise c'est crimes
de guerre sur jupiter ring de guerre sur
jupiter et non non aux objections
non pourquoi dix disent qu'est ce que je
t'ai fait dix panneaux ramic jupe eatx
maximus miss oh mon gars oh mon dieu oh
mon dieu oh oh oh qu'est ce qu'il ya
festisub t'as vu ça allait bien
et là c'est vraiment très jouissif de
faire son nouveau meilleur score parce
que généralement tu as joué une heure
avant d'y arriver à et tu t'es mis en
tête que tu ne quitterait pas jeu tant
que t'as pas battu tous ses records
puis finalement tu as cette grosse
satisfaction [ __ ] [ __ ] quitter le
jeu deux ados leur gentillesse j'ai
pensé à ceux qui n'ont pas eu autant
télécharger flapi berne avant qu'ils ne
soient plus disponibles et j'ai trouvé
deux jeux qui ressemble beaucoup à flapi
bird 1 et qui sont bien évidemment d'une
extrême grande qualité fly birdie voilà
juste l'écran d'accueil quand tu le vois
tu es un peu comme ça je propose d'y
jouer
bien évidemment c'est pas comme s'il y
avait vingt mètres entre les tuyaux duo
et les tuyaux du bas il est absolument
pas fluide alors là aussi j'ai remarqué
un taux qui est extrêmement drôle
pourquoi il ya un logo facebook qui est
à l'envers c'est comme le but suisse
passe quelque chose
absolument pas quand j'appuie sur
l'autre absolument pas et que j'appuie
là ça quitte le jeu assez bon alors je
crois que l'image de fond là c'était un
fond d'écran qui était donné avec
windows 98 perso c'est juste une ligne
une nombre d'oiseaux c'est même pas un
oiseau c'est juste une nombre d'oiseaux
et regardez regardez là le mec m'aider
mais c'est même pas là un tuyau qui
ressort poisse et c'est les cheveux du
tuyau et un autre truc que je comprends
pas trop le ciel et en os pourquoi en
bas il a mis un autre ciel ce jeu a été
développé avec une bouteille d'eau mais
pas un euro alors et encore la bouteille
d'eau est évident
attention j'en ai trouvé un autre si
certains pensent que celui ci n'est pas
à la hauteur il est encore plus ridicule
c'est à dire qu'on par derrière sur un
délire de monde fantastique avec des
licornes et des poneys et en bas sur du
gazon et c'est pas les tuyaux c'est des
cheminées cassez clame andré pujo un
père noël qu'ils savaient plus de sens
quand la suite je connais je connais je
l'est sûrement mon nokia 33 10
et voilà les gens c'est déjà prendre
cette petite vidéo / flops bieber killer
est lui même une imitation de cube pour
un jeu qui est sorti il ya des années en
tout cas télécharger ce marqueur flyers
et choisit avec vos potes je veux que ce
jeu devienne vraiment mondialement connu
il y aura à peu près quatre joueurs je
pense mais c'est déjà ça
tout le monde au vu des cabanes à la
belle invention prime tous avec toi +
moi je n'ai touché
et voilà